yes david well it was so because he
fell in love with him
i did not fall in love yeah you did
relax
first of all fall in love is a very
extreme term that you're
so i came in smooth as [ __ ] right with
this coat on
everyone in five four three
two one hello everybody welcome to
genius frame i am your host meryl song
[Laughter]
and we have a special guest too chef's
son
his name is david so hello chef divasol
hello my name is chef david so
i'm from the furthest part of britain
every day i wake up and i drink tea
and then i have some more tea and then
after i have more tea
i have tea again do you know what mac
and cheese is
so if you guys don't know or if you
haven't been following me on instagram
[ __ ] you just kidding uh we have uh
my netflix show just dropped
finally if you girls go on netflix now
you'll see it it's um it dropped on
december 30th
uh it's called best leftovers ever it
features me
as a judge jackie tone and also rosemary
schrager
uh so basically the concept of this show
that i'm on is
uh we're basically taking leftovers and
we're turning it into something
amazing and so thematically in every
episode they have to do something with
it so for example there's an episode
where
in the first round you have to do a
breakfast with it
and in the second round um you'll have
the fans if i do a really fancy dish
with whatever leftovers that they have
it's so fun i mean it's very
family-friendly
so that's a good thing any kids can
watch it it is the only thing that i've
done that is family friendly i find it
quite amazing that you found
something that's family friendly to work
on hey david sells for the kids
thank god keep it that way let's keep it
that way no we're not doing that
but they uh it's so funny because i got
a bunch of messages from my friends
and every time i post something they
never repost my [ __ ] right this is like
hometown friends i grew up with
and then i see the best like you finally
did something that i could show my
family
[Laughter]
i know i could tell my taiwanese host
family too it's like watch it this
this is my fiancee yeah he's on the tv
and it's actually really fun i enjoyed
it i there were a lot of things i didn't
understand
like what uh certain things that we're
making they're like i'm going to make
bloop bloop
bloop blop
that is literally the worst description
of the show i've ever heard in my life
hello everybody it's a blue blue blue i
know
you come here
if you guys watch this one episode
there's a there's this part
where i [ __ ] died laughing so
rosemary schrager is a very well
renowned chef out in
the uk right she owns her own culinary
school
um obviously i think restaurants too
everything else you know cookbooks
she is the queen of food out there i
call her like female gordon ramsay and
the funniest thing is is that
you know i obviously don't own like any
fine dining restaurants i don't own a
culinary school but
i do own multiple food concepts i've
been involved in food for a very long
time
so when it comes to like knowledge of
food i know a lot i was also 300 pounds
so i ate a lot of [ __ ] food
and i was a very inquisitive eater too
like when i eat something i want to know
where it's from how do you know
i guess we're just like throwing each
other back and forth all these
cuisine feedback as it's do
do we consider you as a chef then well
they were calling me chef and cut which
i don't know if that's the case i mean i
i develop food
so i don't really know if uh if chef is
the term for me
but i'm a restaurateur you know so we do
food development right so with wing
chicks i did food development for that
and um but yeah i guess that kind of
works out i don't really consider myself
a cookie like do you need some kind of
certificate to be considered i don't
think so so
here's here's the thing about cooking
with people that a lot of people don't
understand
and i'll i'll put it to you in
perspective like this if you're a home
cook out there right
uh and let's say you open up a
restaurant you never went to culinary
school
does that mean that you're not a chef
and a cook
you know what i mean it doesn't mean
[ __ ] it's like when somebody says like
i'm a smart person because i went to
college
that doesn't mean [ __ ] they're some of
the dumbest people i know have a college
degree
it's like assuming that somebody's going
to be successful or they're good at what
they do because they went into an
educational institution
doesn't make sense to me i know a lot of
people who went to culinary school and
their food is dick
right they just went to school they
thought that they had a town they
thought they had a gift in it and they
didn't
some of our favorite foods in k-town
those ajimas and those harmonies that
made those recipes
did not go to culinary school are they
considered chefs yeah hell yeah they are
they're chefs and they're cooks hell
yeah they're chefs is chef and cooks
different
i guess chef is i don't know what the
difference is to be honest with you i
guess anybody could be a cook but i
guess a chef might be something a little
more
fancy fancy yeah that's what i thought
yeah
so you know for me when uh somebody
tells me they went to culinary school
it literally means nothing to me it's
like i want to see what you eat
so when you watch some of these episodes
too and we're doing these judging
portions too and once again
i'm not some fancy food guy right i only
can speak about food to what i like so
all the stuff that i'm saying is very
biased
but one of the problems that i saw with
a lot of these home cooks
right when they were coming in is that
my biggest advice to those people were
something that i would do stick to what
you know do what got you to the dance is
what they say
right so none of them are professional
chefs
some of them went to culinary school
okay yeah but they're they're all home
cooks though
so they would you know i was explaining
to you with one of the contestants right
like
when you look at how he cooks it seems
that he knows a lot of terminology
like he knows a lot of different
techniques and whatever right
but his food was some of the stuff that
we really didn't like a lot right
it's because he was trying he's somebody
that is a lot of people online that do
this right when you first start cooking
um you'll you kind of get caught up in
all the fancy [ __ ]
right you want to learn all these
different varied techniques and
but you don't really know like the
foundation of cooking which for me
anyways it's like
um certain techniques and then flavor is
like the most important part right
know how to cook the food and no know
your seasonings so they kind of skip
that part first and they want to impress
people by showing them
showing people that they've done this
high elevated food when we eat food at
home do we give a [ __ ] about elevated
food what do we say
does it taste good or just taste bad
that's all we really care about that's
all most people care about when they do
food
so when they're in this competition the
you know they're doing this like i'm
doing this coddled egg i'm doing
all this other stuff it's really cool
the caudal egg i was like what is caudal
egg
that's like an egg and a ramekin that's
usually with cream right
and i've had that still better i've
literally had that once in my life at a
french restaurant right
and so my thing is like how often do you
make a cuddled egg
would you do this on the show in a 30
minute time frame what is wrong about
making a dish utilizing these leftovers
and doing something a little more common
that we're going to enjoy
eating and so a lot of the times when i
eat people's food
they get caught up in the hype of you
know trying to impress people with food
rather than just making food taste good
the ones that look really good are the
ones that it seemed like they knew
like what the menu was yeah it's like
yeah they've made this before you could
tell when somebody brings out a dish
that they go oh i know what this is
supposed to taste like yeah
so when you try to go too fancy or too
you know
uh i guess i wouldn't say too creative
but you go outside of your box you
better make sure that you can execute it
really well yeah there's some people
that
are like i've never made this before i'm
gonna do it here i'm like why would you
take that chance you don't even know
like
how it's gonna taste like well yeah
that's why when we were on the show i
mean you heard me say that advice like
when uh i ate that raw poached egg
i've never made a poached egg before i
was like what why
why would you make it look gross yeah i
was like why would you make i mean they
they made other great stuff obviously
from the first critiques the next round
all these home cooks and chefs they did
a really great job
but that's what i'm saying it's like you
have a culinary team behind you that
helps you develop certain things
you know maybe their advice would be
good make stuff that you know really
well
it seems like you really enjoyed that
show
oh it was the best experience hands down
you know what i liked about that show
number one um shout out to like magical
elves
they were the production house that that
did the whole thing right and also shout
out to netflix
um super professional very fun
make sure that we were taken care of and
made sure that the show came out great
based on
you know our talents so they didn't
really you know stifle us in that type
of way
they used our improv skills and they
allow us to develop this chemistry
that allowed that show to happen really
well um the cool thing about magical ls2
i think a majority of the higher ups are
all females that's awesome it felt so
it i mean this is just my opinion but
when i when i usually work with women
like they have a very good way
of like being a boss but also showing
this the warmth at the same time
like they they can they can balance that
out so well
you guys just clicked yeah we all
clicked jackie was super funny
rosemary's so
just to go back to rosemary rosemary
there's one part that had me dying on
the show
so when i was saying that she's like an
expert in her cuisine you know
traditional
stuff that you would see that you know
people who went to culinary school
french food
um you know english food or or whatever
like
you know those fancy dishes like i don't
know beef bourguignon
beef wellington like those type of
things right casseroles cassoulet
whatever
when it came to asian food she didn't
really know much it's not in her
wheelhouse
yeah right and she's not afraid to say
like i don't oh i've never had this
stuff
which is really cool i on the other hand
almost exclusively eat asian food
yeah you know so there was a portion
where they were making pbop
and then she could not pronounce
bibimbap and i
i was crying laughing so hard how did
she say the beatnbc
she said it with the most confidence she
goes well
she goes what is this a beaten book a
big she's so funny
she's so funny i i feel like i thought
you came in there as like to be the
funny guy but i feel like
overall like you're funny too but she's
just hilarious i cracked up so much in
this one episode
and i won't say it but it was just like
she was just so natural
like this is a fun show yeah super fun
dude
because our cast chemistry was really
good i hope you guys have another season
coming up i really do too like i
it's very few and far between where
sometimes i get to look at the things
that i do and i say
wow this is really good you know
obviously like you know critics might
disagree the people might be critical of
it but at the end of the day when i look
at stuff and i say am i
smiling or i'm like oh this is very
entertaining yeah i
i that's what i got from this show i
personally like the fact that every time
you came back from the show
you had a good time yeah because i never
complained it there's
nothing to complain about no you didn't
complain you're just like they do this
stuff for me they do that stuff for me
and i'm like why are you gaining weight
because they got so much good food
you know what they're funny you know
what the funny thing is so
so if you guys ever get into
entertainment right and you and you book
a show
or you you go on shows you perform or do
whatever people will ask you uh what do
you want on your writer
right what's writer so that's it's like
snacks
drinks like what do you want to make
your you know comfortable i thought the
room was called writer
so yeah so i was like what do you want a
writer right so it could be like you
know drinks
snacks i don't know some people you know
i need a massage
person or whatever they're right oh
really like i'm a very [ __ ] simple
person you could ask anybody that has
ever booked me for any [ __ ] event
they get shocked at what i ask for they
go oh hey what do you want on your
writer i didn't even know what a writer
was
right and they're like oh what do you
what do you need from us like
snacks or food like we'll get it for you
i was like cool as i wrote so i wrote to
the person i was like
i just need like three bottles of water
and beef
they wrote what like laughing they're
like no seriously like what do you want
i'm like
just some water some water and beef
jerky that's all that's all i need they
thought i was [ __ ] around but that's
really all i need i'm not much of a diva
like
i just need water you guys are going to
give me lunch what more do i need yeah
well i mean now that you know if they
ask you again what would you ask for
same thing just water and beef jerky
really i thought you would ask for
carbonated water
oh yeah i'll upgrade it i was like can i
get some fizzy water this time
and beef jerky no you get the korean
barbecue pork
oh yeah i want this specific thing but i
heard like a lot of people ask for a
specific side i don't really need it
i remember someone was asking i forget
who it was but somebody was like super
picky
where they wanted like specific m ms
oh yeah who was that there's a few
artists but i know aren't a certain
artist that asks for like fiji water
they need a box
of like green juice and i'm like dude
wow that's awesome can you take it home
yeah you could take whatever home i
bought you a bunch of snacks all the
time
because they would always because i only
asked for water and beef juice
for green juice go buy it we're not poor
like what do you need i don't need that
stuff i
mean hey freeze free right
it's i'm just saying if there's any
leftovers you should just bring it over
okay i did
how many times because they would always
in the morning they would give me a tray
of fruits and veggies and i was always
bringing it i
oh cool so that's what i'll be snacking
do you remember on our first
not our first uh but when we
it was like maybe our second or third
time seeing each other we went to a
friend's chapel chapel opening
and it was basically like what is it
like a soft opening or a
re-opening so this is before she and i
actually started dating right
and she left this watch that she is a
cartier watch that she left
at my place and it's gone now i don't
know where the [ __ ] it is
yeah i don't know um but uh my friend
sophia opened up a shabu spot out in
koreatown
and uh it was a soft opening but she
wanted people to try it out
and her shuffle spot was good right just
the location wasn't
really popping at the time it is now but
timing is almost
everything when it comes to like timing
and location and so
uh we weren't dating at the time there's
actually a photo of her on my instagram
i know okay so i didn't go with david by
the way i went with another friend
to go and try it it was actually ed it
was that yeah
and then david was there i was like oh i
don't know if he gave me that watch
then i did give you the watch oh but
anyway i sat down next to ed and then
david sat next to me
and i don't know what happened we were
eating and everything you start making
it out
you wish but it was over
and you know it was free food but i see
a hell of leftover that was untouched
and asking myself this is fresh veggies
and i asked sophia hey where is this all
gonna go and she said
the trash can i'm like that is such a
waste
can i take them and she said go for it
so i got saran wrap and they start
piling the fresh vegetables
and this guy by the way when she says
piling the fresh vegetables and you see
her do this
this is not a correct uh proportion
it was like she went shopping at like at
like [ __ ] h-mart
oh yeah yeah exactly that's how much
leftover there was
untouched and by the way this is when i
wasn't
um i wasn't getting enough money to but
i was on my way to get into the
entertainment actually i wasn't the
entertainment but
she was working at a company called full
screen yeah and i was a freelancer so i
wasn't getting much money so i'm like
hey free vegetables
why not so i'm stacking it up like a
tower
and this guy comes around and asks me
what i'm doing and i'm like i'm taking
this to go and they're like
you're taking free food to go this
podcast is brought to you by bright
sellers are you a
wine skeptic or an occasional wine
drinker like me well either or you're
going to love
bright sellers bright sellers is a wide
subscription service that helps you find
wines you love
while making them more accessible listen
most of us
aren't wine experts but we enjoy
drinking it well bright cellars makes it
easy for you to explore
different types of wines based on your
preferences with just a 30 second quiz
and they will pair you with six unique
personalized wines
and if you are a wine critic you'll love
this too so far i've tried three bottles
that they sent
and i love all three for me i don't want
someone to tell me what a good bottle of
wine is based on what they like
i have to drink it so i want it based on
what i like
what you drink don't make me piss so
give me something i want to drink oh and
also if you don't like what you got in
the first place bright sellers will work
with you
to include a replacement bottle in your
next box so no worries
for genius brain listeners only we are
giving you 50
off your first six bottle orders from
bright sellers by going to
brightsellers.com backslash brain
that's bright sellers c-e-l-l-a-r-s
dot com slash brain you can take their
seven question quiz to get your wine
matches and receive 50
off your six bottle order today yes
david well it was so because he fell in
love
first of all fall in love is a very
extreme term that you're using right now
i sparked
so i came in smooth as [ __ ] right with
this coat on
and right when i walked into the door
this breeze hit and that coat flooded i
saw this
i saw this breeziness it was 80 degrees
and i was like
yo what's up breezy what you taking
these vegetables home what you trying to
take me home with that salad too
ah ha ha that's what happened who do you
think you are
hell no that's what happened so he took
a photo of me
and he wrote something on the hashtag
though
he wrote my future wife and boom look
what happened
manifest what you want all i had to do
was basically take leftover
free leftovers to go and you would be
following me here's the thing
with me here's the thing about that i
just found it really funny because she
wasn't even invited as a guest
she was like uh just a plus one and then
you just see this girl at the end of the
meal
just ransacked the whole kitchen and i'm
like yo i'm helping her this girl has no
shame whatsoever
shave i was helping her less junk in her
trash bin
then i think most people though would be
like oh i'm gonna guess i'm just gonna
eat and then go about my way but you
just approached one of my friends were
like
i'm going to take all your food all the
food i was going to go into the trash
i know why it's the best leftovers ever
saved her
food i helped her you know what the
funny thing is like this is
a precursor to something that happened
later on that was a hot disaster so
when i see somebody take food like that
my assumption is that this person knows
how to cook really well
right wait really you thought of that
when i was taking this left
the first time that she ever cooked for
me right yes
and the this is what i'm not like this
is why i never let it it's not that i
would you wouldn't let it go
because you're talking about this
because you wouldn't let it go that's
why it was so funny
so when somebody says this listen to me
when somebody says this they go
hey i'm gonna make you dinner what does
make you dinner mean by the way
you tell me that you're going to cook
the food the only thing that she cooked
was this rice that was terrible
the mushiest rice ever and then she just
had a bunch of like panchon and side
dishes that she got from the supermarket
so
i was very like she said she was gonna
make me dinner
and so she just had this pre-made food i
was like well at least the rice will be
dope
she puts this rice into this bowl right
that [ __ ] looks like glue because it's
she puts
so much water into it and the funny
thing this is the part that made me
laugh the hardest right
so i'm fat as [ __ ] at this point i'm
200 like 60 pounds 70 pounds whatever
this food is in front of me right and
she's seen me eat before like i eat a
lot of food
she puts for i take one bite and i'm
like man i'm full
i was like i can't and she's like
what would you eat your food you only
took one bite
and she was like what you don't like my
food and i was like well you know
the rice is kind of mushy and her
response is a little irritating
and also the funniest thing a person
could say she knows in her mind
the rice is bad she knows it you know
what you said to me
you go well that's how my grandma makes
it yay it's true
it wasn't bad your grandma doesn't your
grandma does not make bad rice like that
don't put that don't put that on your
grandma all i know is that
well i can't say my mom because she
never made rice from me
let me tell you what you want to say it
was like yeah i kind of messed up on the
rice no because i didn't think it was
myself if i thought it was messed up why
would i
do you think that was good rice hey it
wasn't until you
nagged about my right you're so
sensitive okay here's the thing
okay so let me tell you let me tell them
it's not about that
but you know how you criticize about my
cooking right
so david has lost he lost his taste
his taste bud during this covet time and
when he's cooking when he was cooking
like you know getting like maybe 50 back
of his taste bud he cooked something and
then we were eating it
and i said it's a little bit slightly
too salty
and then he was like what are you
talking about that's why you have rice
with it but later on he finds out okay
maybe it is a little bit too salty and
he started
i was able to tell that you were losing
your confidence of like how your food
should taste like
because he couldn't taste it and it's
also because i said something
i wasn't sad but hold on a second can i
finish my story
go ahead stop butting in please a
terrible rice cooker please continue
that's set if
you don't know your point you just want
you just wanted to trash me that's why
you have no point she literally just
brought that up to trash me go ahead
go ahead i made salty food go ahead
my food is so salty
so here's the thing when i laugh i can't
talk because i'm too busy laughing
so david stop making me laugh oh my god
so since he criticized my
crime hey move your slivers oh god
so ever since he criticized my food i am
so ashamed of making any food for him
because
i don't want to hear him nor see
him not like my food so i make my food
but i don't want to give it to him but
he wants to try it i'm like please don't
try it because if you don't like it then
you're going to hurt my feeling but he's
like i still want to try
and so he tries it it doesn't taste good
did you do a line of coke before you
came in here
what is going on you sound like eminem
on rap god right now i want to come and
say
that what are you saying right now
i want to say give it a breath before
you speak and someone like come and give
up somebody come and say my name
is the exact reason why i can't because
you won't make me laugh
because you won't make me laugh oh [ __ ]
i
can't finish my story
this is why i can't finish my story
because you keep butting it
oh i'm so tired
so sad all i said was that the rice was
mushy
that's it and i will forever remember
that david so
and you knew it was mushy you knew it
was
i didn't say it was terrible i knew it
was mushy but i didn't think it was not
edible
and i think that's the problem i think
the problem was that you fed it to be
thinking that it was okay and also
you said you were gonna make me dinner
i said i was gonna get me dinner i don't
know you know
either way
i either so okay recently i've been
cooking
but i don't want to share my she's got
so much better
david because he will criticize
and when i make something
okay you see why i got a wrap because
you already
[Laughter]
and so when i do make something and he
really likes it he's like this is the
best thing you ever made
and it's the only thing i will eat i'm
like so what about the past all the food
that i have made that you said it was
good
okay okay let me tell you the few things
that she's made that i know that tastes
really
good david you just don't eat my food
what are you saying right now i ate your
food all the time
okay fine so during the pandemic is
during the time that marielle wanted to
try cooking
i cooked before too when i was living
alone yes you did but your food was not
very good you said it was good like the
ribs i made
oh that's different because you did the
uh the that's when you first got the
instant pot
what do you mean that's different oh
instapod's not cooking
is that why it's cooking right what's
the difference
but here's the thing the difference is
like
cooking and following instructions are
two different things right
because now like the more that you try
cooking the more that you're using the
stove you're trying all these seasonings
out
you start getting a palette for stuff
that you personally like and then you
start to understanding
like understanding flavors so when you
were first cooking right you would not
like my food that i made in taiwan
oh i saw photos of it it looked terrible
and so very healthy
so when you were first cooking food you
wouldn't do stuff with like a discerning
palette you would just
make food to what first of all
okay here's the thing i like to eat my
okay my go-to food
is chopped up cucumbers finish
so i love it there was a couple of
things that
when you first start cooking right is
that when you first started to cook the
funniest thing would be that
in my personal opinion she was not a
very good cook right
i say was she's she's getting a lot
better now
am i a great cook slow down slow down
with the word great
so the problem with her food was that
even though she knows that she doesn't
really cook that much or that often
she will look at a recipe and goes i'm
gonna do it my way and i'm like do it
your way
you've never made this dish before like
do it okay
following the instructions do it the way
the person asks first
and then you see what you like or
dislike right and then you can make
those adjustments for somebody who
doesn't cook often
it's good for you to find a foundation
and a basis for what you can work off of
and so you would make these things and
you would take out very important
ingredients that would make the dish
good
and then you would eat it like one when
was that
her banana bread the first one
she served me a brick and the flavor was
fine
and let me tell you something i got a
lot better because back in the day
because of the rice situation i said we
could still eat it and this woman would
not let me eat the banana bread
yeah because you didn't like it why the
next day i woke up it was in the garbage
i'm like
i was still eating that yeah so here's
the thing
okay this is okay i'll give you an
example so recently
um i what is it so recently i put
something on the wall
i you know put the screws on to hang on
hang the whatever oh my god this shelf
oh yeah the shell that's what it was it
was a floating shelf and i put screws on
and put it on there the screws didn't go
all the way in because
i think there were studs or something so
or i just i wasn't strong enough to put
it all the way in
either way i put it up and he looks at
it he goes oh he did a very good job
and looks at it closely and he's like
yeah boy what is this
i did not say that what did you say then
oh he's like
i was all positive you didn't put it in
you know you were positive
okay so okay let's let's take that back
you were all positive
his words were all positive which was
great but his action was
let me undo this and do fix it for you
right in front of your face here's the
thing
if you set everything positive fix it
while i'm not around so i know that i
didn't screw it up
so now i know because he fixed it right
in front of my face
whatever he said out of his mouth was
lot
of a second let me say this real quick
if i showed you a photo of how she
screwed this in you guys would have
cracked the [ __ ] up then why did i
decided well
because you love you did do a good job
you placed it
you placed it in the right place right
it was very level
it's just he just doesn't give a full
compliment it's like oh you did well but
let me fix it for you
okay let me tell you guys
okay guys out there if you're gonna do
all accomplishments
she's a lady she legitimately the right
way if you're gonna compliment it and
you're what do you want what do you want
do it
while the woman is not around okay this
is the funny thing this is how much she
doesn't know about herself
what happened if she went away right and
she came back
and she saw the shelf and these new
screws that were
she would have stopped and been like hey
did you did you fix this thing you know
you wouldn't have done that you were
like did you first of all
hold on you would be like this did you
did you fix
what i did yesterday i thought you said
it was perfect
so you didn't like you lied you lied to
me
you lied how accurate am i right now
this podcast is brought to you by
hawthorne how many of you out there care
about your self-care
if you don't you should because spelling
looking and feeling your best is where
hawthorne comes in
i know for a lot of us out there when it
comes to lotions and deodorants and face
washes you might not know where to start
well screw all that get stuff custom
tailored to match you perfectly all you
got to do is take a fun quiz by
hawthorne to get
that customized self-care bundle made
just for you
it is the easiest thing that i've ever
done and you are going to be
surprised at how accurate these products
are to match your
hair skin body whatever that it is and
this stuff by the way
normally takes a lot of trial and error
and wasting a lot of money well you
don't need to do that with hawthorne
the face lotion that i got perfect it's
not oily but it moisturizes my skin
because i had that mixed skin problem
the deodorant i love it and don't even
get me started about how much i love the
shampoo and conditioner that i got
because my
hair needs the moisturization without
drying it out good skin and hair and
smells come easy with hawthorne and if
you're lonely it's probably because your
skin is ashy and you stink
so let hawthorne hook you up you stink
face
do what i did take hawthorne's quiz
today and get started on your
personalized self-care routine by going
to hawthorne.co
and promo code brain to get 10 off your
first purchase that's
h a w t h o r and e
dot c o promo code brain hawthorne.co
promo code brain no because
i wouldn't have even recognized the
nails because why would i look at the
nails again
it's not like i look at it and be like
oh yeah my nails your nails
let me tell you something those nails
were sticking out so far and then she
placed our mailbox she goes perfect and
walks away i'm like
it's in the right everything i just had
to you know put in
different screws into the wall i just
just do everything yourself
man so how she approaches things
marielle is a creative right so when it
comes to rules and stuff she always
likes to bend these rules
so she gets very frustrated when she
does diy projects
because these diy projects have very
specific instructions here's someone and
then she goes
no no is that even that you can't
measure [ __ ] this is what you do
you slightly measure and you go good
enough then you move on i'm like no
no no these building things are very
specific measurements and you go
good enough so she made this awesome
coffee table by the way
right it took a while it took a while
right but when she did it
she approached it with her good enough
mentality
all right and so when she had this table
when i say screws are sticking out
she made a death trap like
she didn't use the right you want to
hear something really funny though why
so when i first saw you making it right
uh you i saw the the screws that you
were going to use for the table
i actually replaced the screws with
shorter ones and then you
replace the ones i replaced with the
longer ones again
so how did i replace it because
you re you recognize that it wasn't the
screws that you had originally so
you replaced the screws that i replaced
of yours with the wrong ones
and so when i came back i was like she
she replaced the screws that i wait how
did i replace it though
because it was in a container so you had
your original ones laid out
the night before and then i was looking
at and also becky was looking at it and
we're like
those are way too long so no becky
wasn't there because
after so this is what becky and i talked
about so because we were looking at it
this is before you
even did it you had the stuff out and
you were already assembled the table and
then you had all you had to do was add
the screws
and me and becky were like i was like do
you think those are a little too long
she goes yeah we'll just replace it with
some shorter ones you somehow
saw the ones we replaced trying to help
and you were like
these aren't the ones i was using if
they used the wrong spruce
i saw the screws stick out i was like
wait that doesn't make sense because i
went back
and returned that to get a shorter one
no no that was after you found out the
wrong ones
yeah so before that you already had
shorter ones
we had shorter ones and i replaced it
and then you threw those away to use the
longer ones again
you throw them away well you did
something with it so i was trying to
help you without telling you
so i was like cool i'm gonna replace it
and then i saw the screws i was like oh
she she undid my help
yeah well you know people you learn
you learn you learn through your
mistakes right she gets so
frustrated when it comes to doing things
that doesn't work out the way that she
wants
like this table pissed her off
and then when she was asking me these
questions like when you ask a question
to me i'm going to answer it i'll do it
in the nicest way possible i didn't say
anything mean
she goes she goes she goes i hate this i
was like it's not that bad we're just
gonna
shave off the screws she goes we're
gonna we're gonna okay first of all i
was going to get a jigsaw
and then just just get a jigsaw and cut
down
how many 16 screws yeah it's very it's
fast
but then she was like no we're gonna
we're gonna do this
we're taking these cl she bought these
clear plastic boxes
that you could clearly see the screws
through to place it over and i'm like
we could just cut it off you're like you
hate it and then she was mad at me
because the project didn't turn out well
no i didn't hate you but honestly
cutting the screws was just like that's
bizarre no that's not bizarre you people
do that
i know but it was like that's too much
work
for that so what we did is that i just
unscrewed it and put a shorter one
bang bada bing bada boom boom boom boom
so when we were dating there was this
place that we decided to do pottery
right and this is an example of how
mariel just when she's fixated on
something and it doesn't turn out the
way that she wants i actually got
pissed because we were doing this
pottery thing and it was supposed to be
a fun
day i actually recorded that day and it
was supposed to be a vlog but i was so
pissed i just trashed the whole thing
because we're doing this thing she's
very competitive too right and so i'm
making my bowl my bowl looks dope i'm
like it's all smooth and perfect and she
looks over
what i'm doing and i can see her visibly
getting angry and i'm like
did i do something but she was getting
mad because
hers wasn't looking the way it was
supposed to and i was like hey
it's okay we're just here to have fun
and play with the clay she goes no
everybody's done moving on and she's
still there like ghost
you know just still making making this
pot
and she was pissed in a bad mood and i
was like you ruined the day
like i just wanted to make some pottery
why did you have this great because we
never
ended up picking our pottery they shut
down yeah they shut down it wasn't meant
to be
i know i missed my pot my pop was dope
it was
it was it was do you have any um new
year's goals
this year like what are your goals for
this year that you want to
accomplish and people feel a little
weird about new year's goals and i think
like
what people are saying is i don't like
to do new year's goals because i don't
like to put a time limit on one
to be honest at this time with
everything
can we have a goal yeah this isn't that
it doesn't deal with like i haven't
really thought of it
what about you then let me hear yours i
always do new year's reflections
every year to see what i mean you don't
tell me what they are because it's my
personal goals
so here then you ask me in public
you didn't answer well i didn't think
about it that's why i'm asking you be
nicer to my fiance that's a good one put
that into the bucket
thank you that's for you too that's for
you that's for you
so i always do goals right and these new
year's goals by the way
it doesn't mean that it's it i would
like to achieve it this year but if it
doesn't happen
i don't beat myself up about it because
i'll just pick it up and then transfer
it over next year
and then i'll just do it what did you
achieve this year that was your new your
resolution uh kickboxing
get better at it that was this year that
was this year
like and this is why we sparred a lot
and then we did a lot of physical stuff
so what else um i don't know i wrote it
down
but one of the goals that i didn't
accomplish this year was learn a third
language
so that's going to transfer over to this
year what language
i think i'm going to finish up spanish
either spanish or japanese i have to
figure that out i'm just in between
those two
uh spanish is more useful for me right
now but japanese is already like kind of
you're gonna practice with huh with
everybody full
porque nos el avi
yeah that's that's right what does that
mean means
it's it's a type of uh it's a swine it's
a pig
and then we have a also to like oh yeah
with these goals too
um yeah cause it always transfers over
because i had a goal of losing weight
that was like a 20-year goal but it
happened eventually yeah you know and i
think like the important thing is that
when you do these new year's goals you
don't have to beat yourself up if you
don't accomplish it because it just
means that you at least move forward
towards something right because if i
gave up on that one goal where i said i
was going to get healthier
and it didn't happen that year i just
tossed it away it would have never
happened so
it'll just transfer over i think it's
good to set these goals because it
allows you to move towards something
yeah so when people say i don't believe
in new year's goals it's like well it's
not
really saying that in my personal
opinion in ways that you're going to 100
achieve it but it's going to give you a
target to go forward
right yeah yeah so yeah that my
goal this year was to
[Music]
um have a children's book
but pandemic has definitely
took a different route for me to do that
so i had to put a
pause on it why my body wasn't
doing well so basically
when we started working from home just
like the environment situation like i
think it really took a toll on my body
and so i couldn't use my arms well
and you know you gotta draw for that and
so that
the times where i'm not working i had to
rest my arms and so that
now i'm doing much better so i'm trying
to get back onto it but it did take like
six months yeah
so that was unfortunate but like you
said i'm not beating myself
out of it you know so i'll put that for
next year so a few of my goals this year
i do want to complete one
uh solo album for music what
yeah so with z so i want to do that with
z i want to really focus
i've never ever actually focused on
music ever in my life like
new songs or the songs i guess already
created no like new songs
so i've never able i've never been able
to really sit down and do music
right that's is something i i did a
collab album with my buddy paul
we did that now i want to do my own
thing with my own sound and my own vibe
and that's been one of those uh goals
that i've had for a while i just never
been able to focus on it you know
because music was never a priority and
when it became work it used to it
stressed me out
because singing is just something i just
do for fun sure like i'm always just
singing around doing whatever but the
moment i started trying to work on
something it started stressing me out
yeah and it took the the joy out of
something that i do for recreation yeah
um i can work balance that with comedy
and acting and everything else and you
know auditioning and you know like for
example the netflix show or whatever
yeah but when it comes to music it's a
little different
also too uh what i what i found out
about myself is that
i don't really love music as much as
other musicians do
so what like musicians who love music
because i'm around musicians
they love music day and night it's just
music music all the time in the car in
the house
at wherever they're always playing music
and they just need it like it sets their
mood their tone or whatever
you don't really see me do that much you
just have sparks of moments of like
getting really into it and then coming
out and then getting really excited
and coming out and so like music has
never been something i've ever
like i appreciate a lot but it's not
something i've ever really been able to
live in
and then kind of explore it so this next
year i do want to do an album
um five tracks that's it not not a full
ten
just five uh so a short ep like an
extended playlist that's cool
and then uh wrap that up this year and
so i could knock that out on the bucket
list so there's a lot of things that i
have these like bucket list check marks
that i do so once i knock it off
i usually don't go backwards and try to
do it again because it doesn't interest
me
like making my own film check
you know getting like a series check
you know doing stand-up comedy check
you know so there's a lot of things that
i've done that i've already checked off
obviously stand up i
it's not completely checked off because
i i
might want to go ahead and try bigger
venues but it's not like i haven't done
big venues before
it's just um it hasn't really interested
me enough because stand-up is hard so
that takes
a lot of time and effort being on the
road obviously because of pandemic it
doesn't really matter
but i can develop that along the way i'm
always writing stand up 24 7.
but music is one of those things that i
really want to go ahead and do this year
you're so
talented you have a lot of
talent you could write you could sing
play music
you can act you could improv you can
cook
you can
make people hate you that's a special
talent of mine that's a special time
but hate you but love you at the same
time
that's a skill you know i think it's
like
i don't know if it's like talent per se
but i do think it's
i think it's more of i have a very
obsessive personality
so you do have something where you get
hooked into it
you would go to like
you would be up all night studying it
for like at least three weeks to get
to understand what you're doing like
even like bikes yeah before i even
purchased my bike i was it was like
two months of just me researching how a
bike works
you know yeah i mean that's good though
it helps me understand it a lot more
it makes me more it actually has to do
more with my anxiety so
i don't want to make these purchases
knowing that i could have done something
better with it and it [ __ ] up my
anxiety a lot i
started to freak out it's like i wasted
money here i shouldn't have bought that
i shouldn't have done this
so that's interesting so i'm trying to
be knowledgeable about stuff before i go
into it so i don't regret it
i think that's good i'm the exact
opposite
i just get something and i roll with it
yeah i mean that's better though
because that anxiety stuff sucks there's
certain things i don't do that for like
if i have business partners and i know
my role and their role is to know
something that i don't
i trust them to deal with it you know
i'm not going to sit there and be like
okay well i need to learn what they do
oh that's so funny i'm the uh so when it
comes to
work well i guess because i'm in that
profession where i have to know what i'm
doing
um so i do all my research but outside
of that i don't care i'm like i'll just
buy a ticket to
bali and then let's see where it goes
unless
well usually i would have like do i have
a local friend there i do okay i'll just
go i'll swing it but if i'm there with a
group of friends where
they want to do stuff then i have to
plan things out you know the funny thing
is too is like with me and
just to go back to like the whole music
thing when i think about it
a lot of the times when i did these
covers was number one is because i
wanted to do and enjoy something
but my motivation for stuff and i talked
about this on the podcast before
was always to prove somebody wrong right
prove something prove somebody wrong or
show somebody i could do better than
what you can do
right so like even when i was doing
these covers it was say like look i'm a
comedian
i don't really do music but i could i
bet you i could still do music better
than you
you know which is what you're trying to
prove nobody it's just like this
imaginary enemy that i have
you know so i don't get a lot of anger
a lot of anger like i don't really do
that anymore but that's like i would do
these covers and i'm like oh these
people get millions of views doing this
stuff i
sing better than these people or i can
you know or does that make you
entertain i don't know if it's
entertaining but it's like um
i don't do it anymore but before it was
like motivation
it strives you to do something yeah
because it's like this person barely
understands music i could tell by the
way they sing i could tell by this and
this and that and i'm like
i could do better so i would always like
do these renditions of these covers that
were so
different than everybody else's right so
i when i did like honeymoon avenue that
should got
you know whatever three four million
spins and i was like see
i'm not a musician and i could do a
cover better than most people so why
were you like that before and what makes
you not there's no end goal to it
like there's no end goal to it there's
no joy to this like after you do that
what do you what next but what's the
point of this
you should have just created it because
you enjoyed it and you would have
enjoyed the process better
like you had this chip on your shoulder
and this imaginary enemy that's not
there like it's a terrible way for you
to strive towards a goal
so i don't really do that anymore but so
it's like it's
you know for for everybody else to you
know you there are a lot of success
stories where people have a chip on
their shoulder
and they use that as motivation yeah and
i've done that before and honestly like
probably a majority of my senses because
of that
but there wasn't a happiness at the end
of it because after you defeat this
imaginary enemy you just left it
by yourself yeah it's like what's next
do i have to find somebody else to hate
now
like what kind of way of living is that
yeah yeah you know
i think it is a good way to motivate
yourself to
you know reach your goal but definitely
shouldn't be your ultimate goal
yeah singing two is something that's
super hard like um
i don't think people well because we
have stuff like auto-tune and melodyne
you know when you're off-key people can
make you sound good and i think
sometimes a lot of people confuse
great singing and great vocalists with
these people who tune their voice and
you can
always hear in a live performance people
who can sing and people who can do you
want to perform live after your album's
released
no i don't have a yearning to perform
live maybe
i mean i performed live a lot when i
first started doing music
and that was fun i don't really care to
do that as much anymore
but you know that's where you could to
really see
how great of an artist some people are
because the performance aspect of music
is still there too
you know when you're a performer and uh
specifically vocally that's why i love
like following all these like vocal
instagram pages
because you get to see how talented
people are who aren't major artists
and these people are great singers like
they understand music really well
and so a lot of times people will ask
like yo how do i how do i sing
there's so many people out there and you
could even attest and i was trying to
get you to understand this like even
with some of your friends who i think
are really great singers
and i'm like yeah they can sing they
could be
they're on key you know but there's
something missing about their voice
whether it's like a soul
like you're born with it like a
character like great singers
have i think in my personal opinion
great technique
and they also have character in their
voice something unique
something that they're born with or can
they develop it
well people also forget about tone too
when they sing a lot like
let me give you a great example like
bart
bart's not tone deaf and bart actually
doesn't have a terrible voice when he
sings
but bart doesn't know how to use his
voice he doesn't know his range
and he doesn't know how to control his
tone and he also doesn't know how to
control the power in his voice
so you could have like a decent voice
but it doesn't mean that you know how to
sing
right so when people hear bart's like oh
bark can kind of sing it's like kind of
but he can't sing in my personal opinion
right and he knows this too
but babar thinks he's a lot worse than
he actually is and he's not right
he if he did vocal lessons bart could be
pretty decent it's just bart
sings like how he works out like it's
very brash and harsh
and it's not just him it's a lot of
people who who um
who want to sing so they see these
people who are idols who have these
voices right
and they try to imitate what they do
when they don't have their vocal range
nor the talent
yet right and that's stuff that you can
work towards so let me give you an
example so if i
give me a song back midnight oh um
back out one why am i forgetting the
first letters to back at one
it's undeniable it's undeniable
that we should be together um
right versus somebody else so when you
hear that song right
a lot of people try to impress people
with their vocals but they have to
understand when it comes to music and
this is what i've learned from a lot of
people in recording in the booth now
it's music also has a story right how it
starts there's crescendos to music
you can't just go blast 100 throughout
the whole song
so sometimes when people sing these
these these songs they're trying so hard
to sing or impress somebody or put too
much strength into their vocals
they're not paying attention to the
nuance and the tone to when you sing a
song like this
so for example you could be in key when
you make when you sing a song but it
doesn't mean that it sounds good
right it's undeniable that we should be
together
right but if i could be in the same key
but i don't understand tone and nuance
and how i want to sing the song it's
undeniable
that we should be together still in key
doesn't sound good though you're
blasting somebody with your vocals and
that's how a lot of people sing they
don't understand how to record
on a mic it's different when you record
a song it's different than when you
perform
and so they they go oh i'm in key but
you're not that you're talking how do
you
create that soul or
you know what i mean like when i hear
yeah like some of the covers when you
hear it there's like oh they sing
it's it's a very pleasant voice versus
like i feel like i'm about to cry
i think that's just all emotion when
somebody sings right like you have to be
connected to the music
and there's also talent right there's
that one song that we uh that we kept on
listening to it was you took
my heart and gave it a hold
that song makes me tear up when i listen
to it sometimes even through the aching
parts
so i mean when she sings it it sounds
like she's crying
it makes you want to cry so unique once
again if i sing that song
you took my heart and gave it a hold
like my voice is a little shaky right
now but
if i didn't like in that in the way that
you sing that as well
there are certain points that you should
hold out unknown there's certain times
that you should do runs some people are
too gratuitous with their runs but they
can't even do it well
how do you know this did you take music
classes well i took choir but then also
recording a lot
and then listening to other like
musicians that gave me vocal lessons and
it's just
these are the important things so
sometimes like i like i saw a friend of
mine on facebook the other day right
she has a decent voice and she's doing
this thing where she's singing to camera
on facebook
every day and people are like oh your
voice is amazing and i'm listening to it
like no your voice isn't
like you don't know how to use your
voice and it's so kind of hard to listen
to
you know but friends are being nice they
know that she's not that great right
but they're feeding her this idea that
her voice is amazing
and she's also somebody that has a
decent voice it's like bart it's a
decent voice
but she doesn't know what she's doing
with her voice so she'll start off a
song
like uh amazing grace whatever right
so let's say we did that gospel song
right amazing grace
how sweet the sound it's a very plain
way to sing it
but she'll start off amazing
gray it's like you don't you're not
be careful about how you place these
runs it's just too in your face
the song just started right amazing
grace
how sweet the sound
you could do something like that right
and these runs are very basic but
instead but you know how she would start
off
amazing
it's like yo we just started the song
where is this going to end
do that that's so cool i wish like
you know when i watch someone like brian
benign when he's just
so calmly without
any effort he's so effortless and he's
just like
talking but that talking has tones and
his
his he's very very talented though there
are people who are extremely talented
that they just have
they were born with an amazing voice and
they're also technically really good
yeah you know so for me i had to figure
out where my voice lies
i i'm not a true tenor i'm not a true
baritone
so i have this very weird voice where it
stays in the middle so i worked on my
falsetto
so i could hit these voices how did you
know that
just trying to sing and getting vocal
lessons was hard for me i have a very
weird space
where my voice lies well people love
your voice
yeah and even even right now i'm still
trying to find my sound in my voice
right so it's it's still a difficult
process for me
so if anybody out there wants you i mean
i think vocal lessons are great for
people like you should take a vocal
lesson
but you have to understand that there's
like when you sing
it's it's a conversation yeah you know
there's a like you said there's a reason
why when you hear some people sing
you're like
oh that's a good voice but how come i
don't feel it yeah it's like when the
cooking show
yeah i guess like the technique is right
but how come the food doesn't taste good
to me why is this food something that i
don't remember
yeah and that's what it is with with
people who sing and like your vocal
talents like how you develop music and
how you sing
so i i really get envious with people
when they have
such talent it's like because i feel
like okay so like for example there's a
stereotype of like koreans can sing
filipinos can dance and sing your water
yeah
um and so it's true i mean i think
basic like on the basic level i think a
lot of koreans can sing
yeah you know um and i get really
envious when they are like they could
all go to nordivang and sing like
i hate singing like i freaking
hate it so like when people ask me to
see and put me on the spotlight i just
i honestly want to punch their face
unless i'm drunk but then like karaoke
isn't for people to sing well though
it doesn't matter like having that so
like some people
you wanna go ahead go ahead um
it's interesting like when i see the
same mic
that everyone else has and it's there
are people who have the mic
it's like it's like a toothpick for them
it's such a life thing right
for me i see it as like a boulder i'm
like i can't well you're
you're not trying to perform like you're
just having fun like
that's not the point that's not the
point is that i'm not trying to
perform or anything it's just i hate it
i hate it
like i i don't like my voice to begin
with so when i see other people can see
i'm like
how do you just let your voice free like
that because when i
have that mic have you seen me vince
sing karaoke no but i
stress out like he's having fun on his
own
yeah this is having fun so it's fun to
watch him
myself i am stressing out i hate it
but what i'm saying is like you
shouldn't be stressed out that's just
how it
like that's what it is you sing at the
house all the time
yeah because well i do when no one's
around yeah but saying if you just take
that same fun that you're having there
it's the same thing when you do karaoke
you can't like when i ever whenever i
sing karaoke
like the reason why i don't like doing
it is because people expect me to do
something amazing
when really i just want to sing a song
that i can't sing i only like it when
i'm drunk
like i only enjoy karaoke when i'm drunk
what's your what's your go to karaoke
song
i haven't gone to karaoke for so long
uh i don't know
i haven't gone for so long i don't know
mine is
it's usually i like doing the song
because people always sing along
together it's uh my boo usher just
because everybody knows it
so i like to pick songs that everybody
can sing you know because i hate being
put on the spot when you're doing
karaoke
yeah i mean the good singers always get
put on the spot i like to do
ones that are like you could jump around
and dance around like um
uh mine's korean it's dj doc run to you
okay
i run to you and then people just jump
around it's super fun
i like those kind of songs but then yeah
i gotta have a little alcohol in me
she could do a singing lesson right now
no
see again my armpits are sweaty i'm not
liking this i'm like i'm already my
palms are sweaty i hate it
yes i remember boy cause after we kissed
i can only think about your lips
yes i remember boy the moment i knew you
were the one i wanted to spend my life
with
even before you know that the only sin
songs that i was seeing out in public is
trotter
do that then no it's okay
that's the one that you always say yes
it's changing
yeah but either way i look forward to
your album then next year
um i hope so too you don't have any
goals this year
i do i told you what i didn't get to do
my grandma's publish
oh children's book yeah but i don't know
how that's gonna work next year
we'll see this whole work from home
situation
it's so hard it's so hard well
i think it makes it really hard because
just like you with your music you know
how you go in and out
that's how i am with my art too like it
just i can't just sit there
and just start doing it like it really
comes in and out like when you were away
um during cover time that's when i was
just like boom with my art and i just
kept going
but then i can't control that
so i think when i'm stressed out it's
really hard
do you think i stress you out
no that's not what i meant that's
exactly what you just said right now
work from home environment
is really stressful to me what's your
favorite korean song of all time
of all time well i don't
me um
do i have one david are you gonna sing
it for me
cause i ain't gonna sing it for you oh
my god well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast i told you to stop trying
why you keep trying i just want you to
try
i just want you to try i told you to
stop it you just
i just want you to let pay me thousand
dollars i still wouldn't do it for you
a thousand and one dollars no a thousand
and two dollars
no just let loose dude just let loose
i'm gonna kill you david so all right so
that's a wrap today guys
but she didn't mean that much to me no
[Applause]
shut up and now i know you're all i need
thank you guys for listening to so brand
new
tv podcast you can find us on spotify
that i found
and i don't know any other platforms
that this is on but it's also on youtube
thank you everybody have a great night
and happy new years
bye